[Musique]
de l'eau à perte de vue dans le sud du
Pakistan sous ce lac des centaines
d'hectares de champs et de villages
tassima n'a pas quitté son village en
partie submergé elle vit depuis trois
semaines entourées par cette eau
insalubre
on sait que cette eau est sale mais on
n'a pas le choix même si on utilise du
savon pour laver nos vêtements et qu'on
les fait sécher au soleil il reste sale
on boit cette eau on lave notre
vaisselle avec on se lave avec on a peur
aussi de venir ici car il y a des
insectes et des serpents dans l'eau on a
même dû en tuer quelques-uns
cette mère de huit enfants a perdu sa
maison détruite par les flots déchaînés
la famille a trouvé refuge sur une butte
en hauteur dans le village il n'y a
aucune ombre pour se protéger du soleil
brûlant
[Musique]
soin de son bébé mais il y a une
vingtaine de jours plus tôt avant que
les inondations commencent
[Musique]
voilà mon fils
regardez l'état de sa peau
[Musique]
c'est à cause de l'eau
pour consulter un médecin il faut
prendre un bateau et se rendre en
terrain sec mais à Slimane on n'a pas
les moyens avant les inondations il y
avait des sages-femmes qui venaient dans
notre village elle nous guidait sur la
façon de prendre soin de notre bébé
après l'accouchement comme toutes les
routes sont inondées elles ne peuvent
plus venir ici et nous n'avons plus
personne pour nous guider
dans les villes épargnées par les eaux
dans les camps d'urgence les conditions
de vie des femmes ne sont pas meilleures
les autorités locales ont distribué des
tentes mais pas assez pour les centaines
de familles qui ont trouvé refuge ici
Shahida rêve de pouvoir retourner dans
son village toujours sous les eaux le
quotidien ici est très difficile il n'y
a aucun sanitaire
voici les toilettes que nous avons elles
sont en tissu et elles sont inutiles il
n'y a pas de système d'évacuation il n'y
a pas de trou si nous les utilisons une
fois le seul est sale et elles ne sont
plus utilisables nous n'avons pas les
ressources pour construire de vrais
toilettes ou pour construire un système
d'évacuation
vous voyez ces buissons et bien nous
devons donc nous cacher ici en plein air
pour faire nos besoins si quelqu'un
passe par là nous devons nous arrêter et
nous rhabiller rapidement
cet endroit est utilisé aussi bien par
les hommes que par les femmes c'est
aussi ici que le bétail brut donc les
bergers sont souvent là voilà comment
nous vivons nous n'avons pas d'autre
choix
la vie s'organise à ciel ouvert et dans
une grande promiscuité à laquelle ne
sont pas habitués ces familles issues de
milieux traditionnels et conservateurs
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour les distributions d'eau et
de nourriture sont souvent chaotiques et
les femmes qui hostialaient en reparte
souvent les mains vides
de vivre ici car il y a des hommes qui
passent et qui regardent dans nos tentes
voyons pas nos enfants ni les jeunes
femmes de notre famille quand il y a des
distributions de nourriture car nous
avons peur des kidnapping
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là une
ambulance avec à son bord une équipe
médicale se rend dans un campement
d'urgence
Annie Abdul Karim Siron chaque semaine
pour a sculpter les femmes
ces femmes sont issues des zones rurales
elles sont assez conservatrices elles ne
peuvent pas partager leur problème
médicaux avec des médecins hommes sur
tout s'ils sont enceintes ou si elles
ont des problèmes gynécologiques elles
se sentent beaucoup plus à l'aise avec
une femme
plusieurs attendent un enfant sur cette
berge ou des dizaines de familles ont
trouvé refuge à son arrivée quelques
patientes attendent déjà
l'aide-soignante Rabban est enceinte de
7 mois
en quelques minutes la tente se remplit
de femmes de tous âges
elle vivent dans de très mauvaises
conditions sanitaires elles n'ont pas de
toilette pas d'eau propre elles
utilisent des tissus sales quand elles
ont leurs règles et cela cause de
nombreuses infections
des millions de femmes victimes des
inondations sont plongées dans une
extrême précarité elles sont devenues
plus vulnérables que jamais